This video is sponsored by Nebula. Watch my
exclusive podcast episode about
asteroid city only on Nebula.
Wes Anderson has been breaking the fourth
wall from very early on in his career. I mean,
very literally, there are many moments where
he just takes the fourth wall out of a set.
So it's no surprise to find him doing it again
in asteroid city. Here there are three walls
and there's a character standing on this side of
where the fourth wall should be looking straight
at the audience. But asteroid city doesn't just
break the fourth wall, it kind of shatters it
entirely. It makes it difficult to understand
where the fourth wall in the story even is or
if there even is one. It doesn't start inside the
narrative and then break out of the fourth wall,
it starts outside of the fourth wall and
then and kind of moves into the narrative
and back out and all over the place. - Am I not
in this? - Asteroid City is Wes Anderson at his
most narratively and structurally abstract
so far. - I hadn't planned it that way. He
just sort of did it while I was typing. Is it too
extraordinary for you? - Ironically, it seems like
it's within this surreal, poetic narrative limbo
that he finds the freedom to be the most direct
he's ever been about his own personal approach
to life and art. - All that matters is every
second of life on stage and our friendship.
- I wanna talk about why I love this movie so
much and why I think it's surreal chaotic maze
of meta structure actually serves a purpose. -
I still don't understand the play. - What is
Asteroid City about? 73 minutes into the movie,
the play's writer gives us an answer. - Infinity
and I don't know what else. But that's what
Asteroid City, the fictional play within the
movie, within the TV show, the one written by
Conrad Earp and directed by Shubert Green is
about. What is the one written and directed
by Wes Anderson that we see when we go to the
theater about? The list of themes and ideas
that Asteroid City is exploring is almost as long
as the list of names on the movie's poster. If we
look very literally at what's on the surface,
we can see that Asteroid City touches on loss,
grief, America, storytelling, the entertainment
industry, stardom, quarantine, and infinity and
I don't know what else. But I think the
biggest thematic question the movie explores,
the one that underscores everything is, - What's
the cause? What's the meaning? - I don't know
where. - What do those pulses indicate? - What's
that? - Was I ever there? - Meaning in both life
and the creation of art. - Why does Augie Burtis
hand on the quickie griddle? - I think if I had
to say what I think asteroid city is about, I'd
say, I think it's about what it feels like to feel
uncertain about everything. to be surrounded by a
chaotic world that doesn't offer a break from that
uncertainty and most relevant to our current
time, what it feels like to suddenly be cast
into that uncertainty by an outside event,
outside of your control, like a quarantine.
But maybe we're getting ahead of ourselves. -
Where are we, Connie? - Edwin, talk to us. - Okay,
so in the movie, there's the black and white
portion about the making of the play, and
there's the play itself, which we see in color.
Here we are inside the play. War photographer
Augustin Beck and movie star Mitch Campbell sit
in their separate houses under government mandated
quarantine chatting about life and parenthood and
how it relates to their work when suddenly the
conversation takes a turn. "I think I see how I
see us." "Hmm?" "I mean I think I know now what I
realize we are." "Oh right." She starts analyzing
the relationship from a very meta perspective.
"Two catastrophically wounded people who don't
express the depths of their pain because - Because
we don't want to. - This line does pretty
accurately describe what's going on with
their characters. And this is maybe something
an actor would say to somebody else as they were
getting to know them. But it mostly sounds like
something you would say if you were analyzing the
subtext or motivation of this relationship
and these characters. It kind of sounds like
something a writer or actor would say during
the pre-production of a film or a play. That's
a little weird, but it doesn't end there. Also
notice how Nidge mentions that her black eye
isn't real because her character doesn't
get a black eye in the story. It's grease
paint to feel like my character. Huh. Technically
she's talking about the character she's preparing
to play in the script she's working on, but
this statement also explicitly applies to the
character of Mitch Campbell in Asteroid City.
These little moments are ways that Anderson is
breaking and removing the fourth wall, visually
but in the writing. It brings our attention back
to the fact that when we're watching a play or
a movie we're not just watching the characters,
we're actually simultaneously watching the
characters and the actors playing the characters.
In fact in my opinion he didn't just become Augie,
he became you. I think it's kind of tempting to
think about the black and white portions of this
film as kind of decorative framing for the real
story which happens during the play in the color
portions. But if we remove the fourth wall between
these two fictional layers it collapses into one
singular story with the same characters the entire
way through. We have to remember, as the host of
the TV show tells us, that both the real-world
portion of the story and the play are fictional as
a part of a television program about the creative
process. In talking about the creative process,
Wes Anderson is showing us how the writer,
director, and actor's lives influence their
work subtextually. Even if it's not a direct
connection, there's an emotional or personal
one that is connected because the actor and
the character are literally the same person.
That's kind of what our attention is being drawn
to here. This sameness between the actor and the
character is highlighted with certain lines. Take,
for example, when Jeff Goldblum, who is playing
the alien, is asked what the alien is a metaphor
for. He says this. I don't know yet. We don't
pin it down. This mixing of tenses in this line
is making it sound like his character is saying
he doesn't know yet because he's still waiting
on an answer. But the actor is saying on another
level, maybe accidentally, that we don't pin it
down because he's read the script and he knows
that they do never come up with an answer in the
story that he's a part of. You can kind of get
the same thing in this moment where Auggie burns
his hand on the quickie griddle and Mitch Campbell
says, You really did it. That actually happened.
It's almost like her character knew it was going
to happen, but is surprised when it actually does
in the story. I don't know how to explain this
exactly, but it's just this weird fusion where it
feels like the actor is alive in the story and the
story is really happening. It's a bizarre effect,
but it feels very intentional to me. Part of the
subtext of these scenes is that Midge Campbell
and Augie Steenbeck are actually just the actors,
Mercedes Ford and Jones Hall the entire time. But
the subtext of that subtext is that they're
both actually just Jason Schwartzman and
Scarlett Johansson the entire time. - Or just, I
didn't think of that. - I didn't think of that.
- Because I didn't think of that, I should've.
- Did you tell her we were rehearsing again? -
I didn't think of that, I should've. -
When we're watching "Asteroid City," what
we're really watching is Jason Schwartzman
playing Jones Hall, playing Augie Steenbeck,
saying what his character says, which was written
by Conrad Earp, which was written by Wes Anderson,
and you can start to see how the alternate
title of the play was "The Cosmic Wilderness."
By erasing these lines between reality and
fiction, or maybe fusing them together,
the movie explores the question of the meaning
of life and meaning in art simultaneously.
Are we playing our characters right? Am I
performing Thomas Flight correctly? Is Wes
Anderson performing Wes Anderson correctly
if we're in a play who's directing it
and is the director happy with how it's all going?
"Put out that cigarette wipe!" "Oh hold on."
"You meant you'd be ashamed
of yourselves, are you?"
"You can't wake up if you don't fall asleep." So
you're in a play and you're playing a character,
but you don't always know why your character
does the things that they do. So you want to
understand your character's motivation because
you want to know what it all means and you want
to do it right. This is our chance to be
actually worthwhile in our lifetimes. I
see what you mean. And while you're trying to
figure all this out, the world around you is
kind of bubbling with insanity. that are really
happening—shootouts, quarantines, children with
weapons, bombs dropping—all feel kind of distant
and unreal. A suddenly jarring event might make
it difficult to just go on with your life as if
nothing happened, even while you're maybe feeling
like you should maybe be feeling more about
these things than you do. "You feel different?"
"I don't feel anything at all." "Me neither."
Strangely in this movie, the behind the scenes
portion, the part that in theory should be
closer to real life, looks more like a play
and is presented in black and white. It's here in
the interior of the play, asteroid city itself,
even through all the layers of meta-framing
devices and visual artifice that you might
still forget for a moment that you're watching
a play in a movie. Where you might forget,
as we often do watching stories, that you're
watching anything at at all, where a character
stops being a character and starts to feel like
a person with real emotions. - Use your grief. -
And often the way that writers and actors produce
this effect for the viewer is by tapping into
their own actual life experience and personal
emotions. What Anderson is kind of getting at
here is that those moments that feel real and true
through all the layers of fiction are actually
real and true because often as the viewer, What
you're connecting with is not the character,
but the truth of the actor or writer's emotions
or experiences that just happen to be coming
through all of those layers. There's a reality
underneath it all that is making it feel real.
It's when we let our hyper rational thinking
mind fall asleep and allow ourselves to dream.
When we let go of the need for concrete
explanations and our need to really understand
that we can wake up to something that feels real
within the story. - Oh, wow. - I think this is
true within the creation of art, but perhaps it's
also true about life. I don't know. To be honest,
I'm tired. This has been a long week. I don't
know if this video is really making that much
sense or conveying what I'm trying to convey about
this film. And the reality is this whole movie is
a fabrication. So there's no concrete objective
explanation of the film that I can discover and
then give to you here. But to make the fabrication
that is "Asteroid City," the artists working on
this movie tapped into their own real emotions
and life experiences. And sometimes I think I can
sometimes feel that coming through the screen, and
it feels like Augie Steenbeck is really in grief,
even though I know it's just Jason Schwartzman
the whole time. And it feels like the personal
life experience that Anderson is trying
to convey through this movie is that
sometimes when you're trying to do something,
whether it's a creative project or just life,
you might not know if you're doing it right. You
might not know why something happened or even why
you did something. And when you feel like that,
sometimes you have to just keep doing the work
because your cue's coming up and you're wanted
back on stage. - Just keep telling the story.
You're doing them right. - Okay, stop. - Some
people feel like all this meta-framing and
Anderson's visual style pushes away the emotion of
the film and makes everything feel more distant.
And I discussed kind of the ins and outs of this
with Tom from the channel, like stories of old
for our podcast, Cinema of Meaning. - It comes
back to this whole idea of like this. Now two
explicit actors talking about their fictional
characters who- - Right. - Could have had this
emotional moment, but didn't. And yet them
talking about the potentiality of that still
felt to me like the most relevant or the most
emotionally resonant moment of the movie for me.
You can watch or listen to this bonus episode
of Cinema of Meaning exclusively on Nebula,
a creator owned streaming service where you can
find all my usual content early and without any
ads or sponsor reads, as well as a bunch of other
exclusive content from myself and other creators.
Sign up right now with my link to get a special
discount, check out those videos and then check
out all the other great content from creators
on Nebula like stuff from Patrick H. Willems,
Jacob Geller, and even Lindsay Ellis who now
creates content exclusively for Nebula. You
also get access to Nebula classes where you can
watch great classes on film theory from creators
like Patrick and Tom as well as a variety of other
subjects from other great creators. You'll also
find stuff like Jetlag, a show that I really love
and always watch when it airs early on Nebula. The
great thing about Nebula is that when you sign up
using my code and watch stuff there, it directly
supports my channel, allowing me more freedom to
do different kinds of projects and pursue bigger,
more interesting stuff while giving you direct
early ad free access to all the content I make.
It's a very affordable service starting at just
$250 a month when you use my code for the annual
plan. It has great apps for iOS, Android, Google
TV, Roku, and more so you can easily watch the
videos wherever you want. Click the link in the
description below to watch the entire discussion
I had with Tom about Asteroid City, and to support
my channel and other independent creators today.
(upbeat music) (upbeat music) [music]